en este pueblo por encima de las nubes
al extremo oeste de nepal toda la
vecindad está reunida alrededor de esta
casa para una ceremonia
tal como lo establece la tradición hindú
Al treceavo Día tras la desaparición de
una persona este ritual le Abre paso
hacia el paraíso
si tú tenía 20 años murió dando a luz a
su primer hijo una pequeña Niña
ganesh ahora es viudo y padre con tan
solo 22 años
no sé cómo voy a manejar las cosas es
tan pequeña estoy golpeado
decidí educar a mi hija a cualquier
precio por lo que aún no he decidido si
debo continuar mis estudios o empezar a
trabajar esto no ha debido suceder
ganeshi y su hermana están convencidos
una asistencia médica habría podido
salvar a la joven mujer su último
aliento tuvo lugar unas cuantas horas
después de su parto en el centro de
salud del pueblo vecino
menos de dos horas después del parto le
dijeron que podía regresar a su casa
Poco después la llevaron de nuevo porque
empezó a sangrar fueron muy negligentes
deberían haberla mantenido bajo
observación por lo menos 24 horas creo
que habría sobrevivido
desafortunadamente no se trata de un
caso aislado en nepal tres mujeres
mueren diariamente dando a luz sin
contar África subsahariana es una de las
tasas de mortalidad materna más elevadas
del mundo en esas zonas montañosas y
alejadas donde vive el 80% de la
población el hospital más cercano se
encuentra a varias horas A veces varios
días caminando O en vehículo para
hacerle frente a la falta de acceso a
los tratamientos el gobierno creó
cientos de centros de salud este abrió
Hace cuatro años sin embargo tienen sus
límites por ejemplo el ecógrafo no
funciona la mayoría del tiempo y sobre
todo médicos y enfermeras Vienen muy de
vez en cuando son voluntarios tales como
paramila sin diplomas ni formaciones
quienes cuidan de los pacientes tenemos
una máquina para las ecografías pero no
tenemos médico para analizar los
resultados correctamente sin médico
tenemos todas las responsabilidades
nuestros hombros es muy difícil hacemos
lo mejor que podemos pero con suficiente
personal formado las cosas serán
diferentes para esta voluntaria el
establecimiento no cuenta con lo
necesario para hacerle frente a las
complicaciones embarazada de siete meses
cita encuentra sin embargo un apoyo
inexistente hace tan solo unos años es
su tercer embarazo pero el primero con
seguimiento en nepal el 40% de las
mujeres no acuden a ningún control
durante su embarazo 60 kilogramos siguió
perdiendo peso aliméntese correctamente
porque de lo contrario tendrá
complicaciones en el parto perderá mucha
sangre y ya tiene anemia debido a la
falta de alimentos las mujeres no suben
de peso durante su embarazo es el
problema más recurrente en estos casos
la hemorragia es el riesgo más grande la
hemorragia posparto es la primera causa
de muerte materna con frecuencia es
causada por malnutrición y falta de
hierro en la región más de ocho mujeres
de diez dan a luz solas pero futura
madre de 32 años vendrá este centro para
ser asistida por estos voluntarios le
habría gustado tener esta oportunidad
hace quince años en su primer parto su
bebé no sobrevivió
ya no tendré que hacerle frente a la
misma situación ahora que hay un centro
de salud con voluntarios para ayudarme a
dar a luz y garantizar que mi bebé Está
bien de salud sé que muchas mujeres
mueren por supuesto pienso en ello pero
solo puedo orar a Dios para no tener que
vivir la misma situación me paraliza tan
solo pensar en ello de cualquier forma
No contamos con dinero para ir a un
hospital aquí el miedo de dar a luz con
el riesgo de perder su vida supera la
alegría de volverse padres Entonces esta
pareja tendrá su último hijo que sea
niño niño será el último hemos sufrido
mucho en el pasado porque por supuesto
Es peligroso un riesgo real en este
distrito de bayura una mujer tiene 40
veces más posibilidades de morir que en
Francia durante su su parto para tratar
de encontrar una solución Hace cuatro
años el gobierno aportó una solución
ambiciosa movilizar los helicópteros del
ejército nepalés para socorrer a las
mujeres embarazadas de las regiones
aisladas estas misiones son prioritarias
sobre las otras cada mañana el mayor
catca verifica el aparato con su equipo
de técnicos en caso de llamado urgente
hay que reaccionar muy rápido
Generalmente despegamos en 15 minutos
estos pilotos se entrenan diariamente ya
que el Himalaya es un terreno caprichoso
y peligroso vuelo a mucha altura clima
que cambia falta de espacio para
aterrizar operaciones de rescate de alto
riesgo que estos pilotos se sienten
orgullosos de cumplir cada semana le
salvamos la vida a dos o tres mujeres
embarazadas
Hace tres semanas a la mujer que
socorrió lloraba de dolor a lo largo del
vuelo Pero en cuanto vio la ambulancia
medio gracias con una gran sonrisa
eso nos hace sentir muy
en cuatro años más de 200 madres y sus
recién nacidos han podido ser socorridos
año tras año el gobierno se esfuerza por
garantizarles a sus mujeres el derecho a
dar a luz serenamente un objetivo aún
lejano